[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
savouregarde en direct ravi de vous
retrouver toujours masqué mais toujours
très heureuse d'être avec vous au
sommaire ce soir nous recevons Laurent
Berger le patron de la CFDT l'occasion
de passer au crible avec lui l'action du
gouvernement alors qu'une vague sans
précédent de faillite menace comment
contenir l'hémorragie face à une crise
sanitaire qui n'en finit plus les
mesures d'urgence sont-elles à la
hauteur y a-t-il des propositions pour
les améliorer on en débat dans un
instant avec nos invités nous évoquerons
aussi la crise sociale avec tous ces
nouveaux visages de la pauvreté on a vu
arriver des gens qu'on avait jamais vu
toutes les associations caritatives en
témoignent la demande d'aide alimentaire
explose qui sont ces nouveaux publics
qui basculent ceux qui n'ont plus rien
sont-ils les grands oubliés nous en
parlerons également enfin on s'arrêtera
sur les vaccins c'est l'une des rares
bonnes nouvelles en cette période
pesante la campagne vaccinale va
commencer en janvier c'est ce que promet
le gouvernement mais La France est-Elle
prête décryptage à suivre dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission voilà
pour le programme
#vr n'oubliez pas tout de suite à ce
débat
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi
elle s'est fait bonsoir Laurent Berger
ravi de vous accueillir sur ce plateau
secrétaire général de la CFDT vous avez
publié quelques semaines à peine sortir
de la crise agir vite penser loin c'est
chez Kalman Levy à l'époque ont déjà le
monde d'après il s'éloigne de plus en
plus face à cette crise sanitaire qui
n'en finit pas on en dira un mot tout à
l'heure mais on avait envie de vous
proposer un débat avec Roland Lescure
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes député
en marche et surtout président de la
commission des affaires économiques à
l'Assemblée nationale on va débattre à
la fois des réponses que le gouvernement
apporte depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire sont-elles justes sont-elles
efficaces surtout par rapport à cette
pauvreté qui nous s'auto visage et envie
de dire ce soir Jean merckart le
porte-parole français Europe du Secours
Catholique va nous rejoindre dans un
instant enfin bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir
Myriam Stéphane blackovski à mes côtés
comme tous les soirs qui va ouvrir ce
débat avec son billet d'actu si j'ai
bien compris tout de suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir la pauvreté
explose si j'ai bien compris Myriam les
principales victimes de la crise du
covid en France ce sont les plus démunis
alors depuis le début de la crise les
milliardaires eux ont gagné encore plus
de milliards les Français les plus
riches ont épargné des sommes
considérables sinon les retraités les
fonctionnaires les salariés qui ont
bénéficier du chômage partiel eux ont
gardé la tête hors de l'eau en revanche
la crise a eu un effet dévastateur sur
sur les plus démunis quelques chiffres
qu'on peut citer les demandes du RSA en
estime qu'elles ont remonté d'environ
10% l'aide alimentaire vous en parliez
accueil 20 à 30% de personnes en plus
qui cherchent des repas gratuits donc au
total on estime qu'il y a environ un
million de Français qui ont basculé dans
la pauvreté depuis le début
le gouvernement ne reste pas inactif
j'imagine alors non on ne peut pas dire
que le gouvernement est inactif mais en
même temps on n'a pas non plus
l'impression que la lutte contre la
pauvreté soit vraiment la priorité du
gouvernement vous voyez dans le plan de
relance quand on nous a beaucoup parlé
il y avait 100 milliards il y a 20
milliards qui sont consacrés à des
baisses d'impôts pour les entreprises en
revanche quand on additionne toutes les
mesures pour les plus précaires on
arrive même pas à 2 milliards vous voyez
ça fait 10 fois moins en fait on a
l'impression que quand il s'agit d'aider
les plus pauvres le gouvernement a
tendance à être un petit peu radin donc
par exemple vous savez on a eu une cette
idée de d'une aide de 150 € bah au début
j'encaisse ne voulait pas que c'était de
modique de 150 euros soit versé à ceux
qui touchent l'APL qui sont souvent des
étudiants donc il a quand même pris deux
jours pour réfléchir c'est dit que
c'était peut-être un petit coup de pouce
qu'on pouvait donner pour aider les
jeunes donc il a finalement accordé
cette prime de 150 euros pour les les
bénéficiaires de l'APL effectivement vu
l'ampleur de la crise en 50 euros
franchement c'est pas énorme alors comme
vous en une fois hein surtout que le
gouvernement disait ben que quoi qu'il
en coûte il était prêt à dépenser pour
faire face à la crise donc puisque
c'était quoi qu'il en coûte on aurait pu
imaginer que les plus pauvres
bénéficient d'un effort supplémentaire
comme par exemple certains syndicales
demandent donc Laurent Berger une hausse
du RSA je crois que vous me demandiez
vous 100 euros bon alors le problème
c'est que le président Macron sur ce
point il est totalement inflexible on
l'écoute moi je tiens aussi à une chose
c'est qu'on ne perd pas nos fondamentaux
nos fondamentaux c'est la lutte contre
la pauvreté par le retour à l'activité
et le travail et plus on augmente de
manière unilatérale
tous nos minimas sociaux on les rebaisse
jamais après plus
on rend difficile
le retour à l'activité oui donc selon le
professeur chef de l'État Emmanuel
Macron le remède à la pauvreté c'est
l'emploi exactement Myriam merci vous
paraître un peu bizarre sachant que
l'année prochaine la Banque de France
nous dit que le taux de chômage va
dépasser le 11% mais que voulez-vous on
se refait pas vous vous souvenez qu'en
2018 il était filmé dans son bureau il
disait dans ce pays on claque un pognon
dingue pour les minima sociaux et c'est
pas très efficace donc manifestement il
est toujours sur la même ligne mais les
syndicats qui sont présentés ici par
Laurent Berger sont pas les seuls à
réclamer une hausse des minima sociaux
il y a même des grands patrons qui sont
sur cette ligne là bah voilà par exemple
Louis Schweitzer l'ancien patron de
Renault il était sur BFM Business et lui
il voulait une hausse durable donc pas
juste une petite prime une hausse
durable des minima sociaux alors
évidemment vous pourriez me dire mais
est-ce que ça va pas coûter un pognon
dingue vous n'avez pas dit mais vous
pourriez dire je ne l'ai pas dit donc
rassurez-vous Myriam j'ai la solution je
vous ai trouvé un autre grand patron qui
lui aussi réclame une hausse des minima
sociaux mais qui en plus à une solution
pour financer cette hausse c'est Louis
Gallois on l'écoute
je ne suis pas contre le fait qu'il y
ait une solidarité qui s'exprime dans la
crise par des impôts sur les personnes
les plus riches ça peut être de
nouvelles tranches d'impôt sur le revenu
qui peut être provisoire mais je pense
que il faut que il y ait cette
solidarité puisse s'exprimer d'une
certaine manière on ne comprendrait pas
que c'est pas parce que ce sont les
pauvres qui ont payé la crise au plus au
prix fort c'est eux qui ont le plus subi
le choc alors vous voyez le gouvernement
a dépensé coûte que coûte quoi qu'il en
coûte plutôt quand il s'agissait du
chômage partiel quand il s'agissait de
d'aider des entreprises et ça ça a été
plutôt efficace mais là quand on va se
développer la pauvreté en France on a
sentiments qui a comme un effet de bons
à retardement et donc la question qu'on
se pose est-ce qu'il faudrait pas plus
aider les démunis si on veut pas éviter
une explosion sociale peut-être même dès
l'année prochaine merci beaucoup voilà
le décor est planté Laurent Berger pour
rebondir est-ce que vous diriez que les
plus modestes les plus précaire sont les
grands oubliés de cette crise sanitaire
et du gouvernement je dirais que les
personnes qui sont en situation de
pauvreté ou qui sont en précarité ne
sont pas suffisamment aidés moi je suis
pas dans le binaire j'ai jamais ce type
de réflexion on peut pas dire qu'il ne
sait rien passer d'abord il faut le dire
dans le quoi qu'il en coûte il y a
toutes les le soutien au travailleur à
travers l'activité partielle ça ça
évidemment éviter contrairement à ce
qu'on a pu voir dans d'autres pays
européens des travailleurs de tomber
dans dans la situation heureusement
qu'il était le chômage partiel c'est dit
mais sur la situation spécifique des
personnes qui sont en situation de
pauvreté ou qui sont sur le fil de
rasoir et qui risquent d'y tomber il y a
pas ça pas été à la hauteur moi dès le
début du plan de relance j'ai dit que le
grand absent de ce plan de relance
c'était le soutien à la demande à
travers une aide spécifique des
personnes les plus fragiles les plus en
difficulté en situation de pauvreté à
travers présentation du RSA
l'instauration de RSA jeune je crois
qu'il y a un angle spécifique
à partir de 25 ans
temporaire pour le coup mais un chèque
relance qui soit à la hauteur pour que
on ne tolère pas dans notre pays qu'il y
ait 10% 10 millions de personnes qui
sont en situation pauvreté et un enfant
sur 5 qui soit en situation de pauvreté
alors on va parler des solutions je
voudrais qu'on reste sur le diagnostic
j'en profite si vous n'étiez pas là
avant c'est parce qu'on a des raisons de
place ces contraintes de sécurité
sanitaire Jean-Marc art bonsoir je le
disais dans le sommaire vous êtes le
porte-parole français Europe du Secours
Catholique vous allez nous dire dans un
instant qui vous voyez venir dans votre
association mais d'abord Roland Lescure
est-ce que vous vous avez au fond
anticiper cette grande vague de pauvreté
est-ce que est-ce que c'est à la hauteur
on a l'impression franchement quand on
regarde le plan de relance on n'est même
pas 1% pour les plus modestes c'est une
faute alors d'abord on est un peu plus
que 1% et puis je voudrais revenir sur
ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure quand
même et je veux surtout pas botter en
touche il y a un sujet sur les plus
précaires Laurent Berger de l'a dit mais
j'en ai un peu marre je dois le dire
vraiment franchement qu'on oppose tout
le temps les entreprises
et les Françaises et les Français parce
que si on baisse l'impôt de production
pour les entreprises c'est pas pour
enrichir Jeff Bezos c'est pour avoir
plus d'entreprises en France et plus
d'emploi quand on fait du chômage
partiel c'est pour s'assurer que le lien
d'emploi avec l'entreprise soit
maintenue pour d'urgence sociale
de milliards qu'on a mis sur le chômage
partiel c'est pas pour aider les patrons
c'est pour s'assurer qu'on garde le lien
d'emploi avec l'entreprise pour la
plupart des employés français pour
éviter justement du temps dans la
pauvreté
de l'année des quatre des quatre plans
d'urgence qu'on a voté depuis le
printemps ensuite
je pense qu'il faut pas opposer
c'est sur le concret parce que plus de
gens pourront rester dans l'entreprise
garder ce lien à l'entreprise moi on en
aura qui tomberont dans la pauvreté
maintenant c'est vrai les chiffres le
montrent on parlait d'un million en plus
il y a des gens qui sont frappés par une
extrême précarité y compris d'ailleurs
des gens qui travaillent et c'est cela
qu'il faut aider on l'a fait on l'a
peut-être pas fait assez mais on l'a
fait et on l'a fait de manière
importante quand même je veux juste
rappeler pour les étudiants on l'a
peut-être pas fait assez est-ce que
c'est une question que vous lancez comme
ça dans le débat ou c'est ce que vous
pensez vous perdez moi je pense qu'il
faut qu'on évalue et c'est vrai que les
chiffres qui sont sortis aujourd'hui les
témoignages de leur coin sur le terrain
sont assez saisissants donc il faut
qu'on les prenne à bord mais faut pas
oublier que sur les appels sur le RSA en
tout cas sur ceux qui sont bénéficiaires
du RSA on a fait des choses il y a
maintenant c'était il y a quatre
semaines le Premier ministre les a
annoncé on a fait des choses pour les
étudiants on a aussi mis en place un
dispositif d'emploi des jeunes parce que
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec le
diagnostic du professeur Macron comme
vous l'appelez mais moi je suis
convaincu
25 ans que on a fait un choix qui ne mon
point de vue n'a pas été c'est efficace
et qu'aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ce
qu'on essaye de faire notamment pour les
jeunes c'est de les ramener vers
l'emploi et juste en passant ça marche
c'est-à-dire que les primes à l'embauche
pour les jeunes qu'on a annoncé qu'on a
mis en place de cet été elle se
traduisent aujourd'hui par des embauches
de jeunes qu'il a encore sont des jeunes
qui ne tomberont pas dans la pauvreté
c'est important j'entends ce que vous
dites mais je pense qu'on est dans une
situation exceptionnelle et je voudrais
qu'on la décrive avec vous je vous donne
la parole dans un instant mais on va
d'abord regarder le sujet le reportage
d'Hélène Bonduelle qui s'est rendu dans
deux antennes celle des Restos du coeur
et du Secours populaire reportage une
heure avant l'ouverture ils sont déjà
nombreux à faire la queue devant ce
local parisien des Restos du cœur le
responsable lui guette l'arrivée des
nouvelles dans resalimentaire on va
donner du lait de la des clémentines
d'abord il y a des dates c'est plus que
bienvenue parce que c'est on n'avait pas
assez de stocks pas assez de stocks car
ici on est passé de 800 à 1100
bénéficiaires en quelques mois seulement
principalement les gens qui sont au
chômage récemment quoi avec la crise du
covid et les gens qui étaient pas qui
c'est pas dans le besoin qui qui sont
maintenant quoi par la force des choses
quoi vous les voyez arriver chez vous
de nouveaux profils de personnes que
deux confinement successifs ont fait
basculer dans la précarité dans un
premier temps il y avait ceux avec les
écoles est fermée donc ils avaient
besoin de nouvelles des enfants le midi
après il y a ceux qui ont perdu leur
emploi ça touche des personnes qui
avaient des emplois entre guillemets
précaires et dit à la restauration où il
y est comment dirais aux personnes
qui font du nettoyage à domicile
de lait voilà c'est aussi le cas
d'Arlette assistante petit enfant qui a
dû se résoudre à venir chercher des
colis alimentaires j'ai fait en fait
petite enfance et après par contre il y
a eu la première vague et voilà c'est
tout déclenché j'ai perdu l'emploi et là
je suis obligé maintenant de venir au
resto pour les ravitailler grâce à ses
denrées elle va pouvoir se nourrir
pendant deux semaines mais pousser la
porte des associations caritatives et
souvent un pas difficile à franchir la
première fois on a l'expérience un peu
des personnes qui
qui sont un peu devant la porte qui
n'osent pas rentrer et qui ont la gêne
de vouloir passer cette porte c'est pas
aussi simple que ça de passer une porte
en disant est-ce que vous avez quelque
chose à manger voilà madame
je sais caché des côtes de porc une
pizza le Secours populaire français a vu
ses demandes d'aide augmenter de 40 %
depuis le début de la crise et comme ici
dans les Yvelines les collectes sont
plus difficiles à organiser avant on
pouvait organiser des initiatives de
collecte financières comme des loto ou
des braderies qui nous permettaient de
financer nos actions aujourd'hui avec le
confinement un peu plus du tout on avait
aussi les collectes en magasin qui nous
permettaient de collecter des produits
alimentaires d'hygiène ou de bébé qui
sont aujourd'hui vraiment
ralentis et la tâche est d'autant plus
difficile que la plupart des bénévoles
sont en grande majorité
âgées donc plus exposée au virus
Jean-Marc art vous qui êtes sur le
terrain qu'est-ce qui vous frappe le
plus on parle des jeunes on parle des
chômeurs mais il y a aussi beaucoup
d'actifs de gens qui au fond anciennes
des petits contrats non pas assez pour
toucher le chômage partiel n'ont pas
travailler assez longtemps des
intérimaires mais qui n'ont pas non plus
le seuil pour toucher les minima sociaux
là sont dans un trou dans la raquette si
on peut dire ce qui me frappe en voyant
les images là c'est que effectivement
c'est il faut se résoudre aller faire
appel à l'aide alimentaire c'est très
difficile en fait d'avoir à demander de
l'aide pour pour nourrir ses enfants
et en fait ce phénomène là il date pas
du covid c'est-à-dire que en 2019 déjà
il y avait 5,5 millions de Français qui
avaient besoin de l'aide alimentaire
pour se nourrir pour nourrir leurs
enfants c'est un doublement par rapport
à 2009
alors avec le covid et effectivement le
basculement de tout un tas de personnes
qui sont sorties avec des revenus du
travail de jeunes qui
s'apprêtaient à rentrer sur le marché du
travail le basculement toutes ces
populations là fait monter encore les
chiffres et Olivier Véran parler en
septembre d'un risque de 8 millions de
personnes qui ont besoin d'avoir recours
à l'aide alimentaire la solution est
assez simple
12% de la population française qui a
recourir dans la sixième puissance
économique mondiale pour nous
attendez que très concrètement il y a
effectivement des trous dans la raquette
de notre système de protection sociale à
la fois les Français ont pu se rendre
compte avec le la crise sanitaire
que cette protection sociale était
précieuse elle nous protège avec le
chômage partiel avec le système de santé
malgré ses faiblesses mais il y a tout
un tas de population qui passe à travers
les mailles du filet justement de ces
contrats précaires de ces contrats
d'intérim ce qui remonte quand on
regarde les reportages c'est ces
situations finalement vous avez enchaîné
des contrats très courts mais vous
n'avez pas travaillé assez longtemps
pour toucher le chômage partiel mais en
même temps vous gagnez ton 1700 1800
euros et vous ça vous ouvre pas droit au
RSA il y en a beaucoup dans ce cas là
c'est effectivement le type de situation
et on ne touche rien quand on a entre 18
et 25 ans Laurent Berger touche rien
c'est tout à fait juste quand on a entre
18 et 25 ans on a tout un tas de jeunes
qui soient qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail et qui sont parfois diplômés ou
non diplômés peu importe sa manière et
qui passe en travers les mailles du
filet des dispositifs existants il y a
des dispositifs existants qui s'appelle
la garantie jeune le passé a qui permet
d'être accompagné d'avoir une indemnités
pour s'insérer professionnellement mais
il y a des jeunes qui ne rentrent pas
dans ces dispositifs parce qu'ils n'en
n'ont pas besoin en termes
d'accompagnement
ce matin sur une antenne le le président
des Restos du Coeur disait qu'il y avait
un afflu de jeunes énormes et qu'ils
avaient même été obligés de faire une
distribution à la Cité Universitaire
parce que il y a aussi ce phénomène là
pour des jeunes étudiants par exemple il
y avait parfois les petits boulots le
petit boulot c'était évidemment dans
l'hôtellerie la restauration on sait ce
qu'il en est aujourd'hui c'était du
baby-sitting qui ne s'opère plus non
plus parce que les parents font pas
forcément sortir ou en ont pas forcément
besoin donc il y a des il y a des trous
dans la raquette la question est elle
est pas est-ce que elle est elle est de
deux heures est-ce qu'on comble les
trous dans la raquette
est-ce que on regarde en face la
situation de la pauvreté dans notre pays
et le RSA par rapport au SMIC par
rapport à quand le RMI a été instauré il
a totalement dégringolé il a totalement
dégringolé et moi je ne suis pas pour
une société dans son montant dans sa
proportion par rapport par rapport à son
indexation sur le SMIC par exemple
il a baissé et moi je suis pour une
société de l'émancipation où chacun a la
possibilité de s'en sortir évidemment
que le travail s'est extrêmement
important mais la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui y compris des gens qui
travaillent d'une part et d'autre part
des gens qui n'ont pas accès au travail
pour l'instant et ont subi une crise
économique non pas de quoi vivre
décembre
une augmentation du RSA il faut
instaurer un RSA jeune et il faut avoir
des politiques ciblées et il faut un
quatrième élément si je peux me
permettre il faut un soutien massif
massif aux associations qui viennent aux
personnes les plus émulées
le RSA c'est très concret de combien et
puis je vous donne la parole rôle je
l'ai déjà dit je pense que pour revenir
à un niveau par rapport au salaire
minimum qui soit celui qui existait dans
les années 80 il faut il faut il faut
l'augmenter de 100 euros et c'est une
première étape les associations avec
lesquelles nous travaillons dans le
cadre du Pacte du pouvoir de vivre nous
disent que ce ne sonne peut-être qu'une
première étape mais faisons cette étape
elle arrêtons moi je veux juste le dire
que il faut arrêter c'est de considérer
que ce serait de l'assistanat c'est le
raisonnement d'Emmanuel Macron non je ne
comprenais pas
si tu es personne je dis qu'il faut
arrêter de considérer que cette
assistant à moi je vais vous dire à
chaque fois que je fais ce type de
d'appel sur la question de la pauvreté
qui n'est pas très qui est un peu
singulière pour un syndicaliste vous le
reconnaîtrez je reçois des courriers des
insultes en disant mais c'est quoi ton
histoire tu défends les assister etc
faut sortir de cette logique là faut
sortir de cette logique là on ne se
grandira dans la société que c'est aussi
on se préoccupe d'abord de ceux qui sont
le plus en difficulté très clair Roland
augmentation
c'est qu'il faut arrêter de s'opposer
dans ce pays d'opposer les uns contre
les autres quand même je voudrais dire
une chose importante c'est l'Insee quand
ils ont sorti leur chiffre ont aussi
annoncé hier c'était pas grand chose
mais que la pauvreté en 2019 elle avait
commencé à baisser et c'est pas par
hasard c'est parce que par la prime
d'activité qui effectivement a tendance
à augmenter les quarts de rémunération
entre le SMIC et le RSA parce qu'on a
fait sur les aides à l'endroit où par le
fait qu'on a rendu la France un peu plus
attractivité
même temporairement le logiciel de
départ moi je pense que on l'a fait un
peu alors peut-être pas assez mais votre
collègue va dit tout à l'heure le
Premier ministre a mis deux jours à
réaliser que ça serait peut-être bien de
faire quelque chose pour les jeunes on
en est avec Stan Guérini au mouvement
marche en grande partie responsable on a
beaucoup insisté pour que dans les
mesures de progreté qui ont été
annoncées il y a 3-4 semaines les jeunes
fois concernés alors qu'ils ne n'était
pas effectivement au départ je veux
juste qu'on n'oublie pas que c'est aussi
en créant de l'emploi c'est aussi en
créant de l'éducation ensuite au moins
de 25 ans ça c'est pas c'est pas sur la
table
je suis Papou c'est un désaccordant
parce que je pense que à court terme on
peut sans doute faire plus je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure on avait déjà fait et en
partie grâce à nous il y a 4 semaines
quand ça a été annoncé on a un sujet
ponctuel de maintien des gens qui sont
aujourd'hui dans extrême pauvreté et
Laurent l'a dit il faut aussi Laurent
Berger il faut aussi davantage aider les
associations parce qu'on a vu le travail
exceptionnels qui sont faites il y a des
choses qui sont prévues dans le plan de
relance en passant mais en revanche je
ne crois pas c'est pas une histoire
d'assistanat mais je ne crois pas que
les jeunes de 18 à 25 ans doivent avoir
un revenu minimum j'allais dire quel que
soit les conditions parce qu'on a un
défi effectivement moi j'ai vécu au
Canada pendant 8 ans
tous les jeunes travaillent tous les
jeunes travaillent en fait plus qu'en
France et on a une insertion des jeunes
sur le marché du travail qui je voudrais
reconnaître est plus efficace en
revanche ce qu'ils ont fait ce qu'on n'a
pas fait c'est que pendant tout l'été là
les jeunes qui ne pouvaient pas
travailler ont eu 2000 dollars donc
presque 2000 euros chacun donc la
question c'est que aujourd'hui il y a
pas de travail
je pense qu'il faut qu'on réfléchisse
davantage encore à aider les jeunes
aujourd'hui mais je ne crois pas moi un
RSA pour tous et là-dessus je sais qu'on
est pas là
ce débat là il court depuis la création
du RMI
et le sujet c'était mais est-ce qu'on
est désincite pas finalement des jeunes
à s'insérer professionnellement il y a
on a la chance d'avoir de très bons
économies dans ce pays il y en a une qui
s'appelle Esther Duflot qui a prouvé par
l'économie qui a prouvé par un certain
nombre de ces travaux que d'aller de
d'avoir une indemnité une allocation peu
importe comment on appelle ça d'un
niveau suffisant pour survivre n'était
pas du tout des incitatifs à prendre une
activité moi j'étais mon métier
d'origine c'est conseillé en insertion
professionnelle j'ai constaté et j'étais
quand j'ai lu les travaux des stars
Duflot j'étais extrêmement satisfait
parce que c'était un ressenti très
profond parmi les professionnels et mes
collègues etc lorsque une personne en
bavait pour se nourrir faire vivre
décemment ses enfants sa propension à
reprendre une activité était beaucoup
plus faible que lorsque la question
économique était réglée entre guillemets
c'est à dire lorsque de toute façon
était meilleure et je crois que c'est
vrai pour des jeunes c'est vrai pour des
jeunes aussi parce que je ne crois pas
que c'est si on verse une allocation un
RSA pour les jeunes on les empêchera
d'accéder à l'emploi je ne crois pas du
tout à ça mais c'est vrai que c'est un
débat
Jean-Marc vous qu'est-ce que vous
attendez très concrètement
des pouvoirs publics de cette majorité
nous on fait exactement le même constat
que Laurent Berger c'est-à-dire que
effectivement les personnes que nous
accompagnons on a reçu l'année dernière
un million 400 000 personnes qu'est-ce
qu'elle demande deux choses elles
veulent contribuer à la société par leur
travail par une activité utile et elles
veulent être protégées aujourd'hui
contribuer à la société étant donné la
situation du marché de l'emploi mais
c'était déjà vrai hier c'est compliqué
il y a un certain nombre de personnes
qui sont quand même privées durablement
d'emploi on ne peut pas leur imputer
l'entière responsabilité
et la protection elle est pas toujours
au rendez-vous et
je crois avaient parlé dans le point
pauvreté ça nous ramène à avant la crise
sanitaire d'un revenu universel
d'activités
où est-ce qu'on doit attendre un peu
avant parce que la formation est
importante parce que l'apprentissage
d'un métier et oui parce que parfois
parfois la galère et je parle pas de
l'ultra galère qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
parce que là on est dans une situation
particulière qu'on doit adresser je le
reconnais on fait beaucoup pour les
associations est-ce qu'on fait assez
pour les genoux
le président des Restos du Coeur cité
cette image qui choqué quand on l'écoute
ce sont des jeunes livreurs des livreurs
de repas on les voit tant toutes les
grandes voilà qui nourrissent les gens
et qui se retrouvent le soir même dans
les banques alimentaires vous savez
quand intuitivement on a dit attention
il y a une augmentation de la pauvreté
suite au confinement etc ce qu'on nous a
renvoyé parce qu'on travaille avec le
Secours Catholique avec d'autres
associations qui sont les meilleures
observateurs je suis désolé de le dire
mais on nous a dit oui mais on ne
retrouve pas ça dans les chiffres etc et
on a dit mais regardez du côté des
travailleurs indépendants mais très
dépendant économiquement regardez du
côté des jeunes étudiants regardez et
c'est vrai qu'il y a pas une corde de
population uniforme c'est diffus c'est
diffus parce que des trous dans la
raquette existent dans notre système de
protection sociale et il faut
reconnaître que quand en avril mai on a
dit il y a un trou à tel endroit le
gouvernement parfois à répondu mais
hélas c'est diffus et on y répond pas
que par des petits bouts de dispositif
on y répondra par une vraie logique
d'éradication de la pauvreté et ça ça
nécessite des revenus pour les personnes
qui la suivent on va pas forcément vous
mettre d'accord on l'entend mais
j'aimerais savoir dans les associations
est-ce que la solidarité
joue davantage est-ce que par exemple
alors que à certaines périodes ça peut
être difficile vous ne souffrez pas de
de d'approvisionnement de denrées
alimentaires on donne la grande
distribution donne on peut on peut
trouver maintenant suffisamment
dans le besoin il peut y avoir des
soucis et là maintenant l'Union
européenne vient de d'annoncer un
surcroît de financement pour l'aide
alimentaire maintenant encore une fois
du point de vue du Secours Catholique le
projet d'un pays comme la France ne
saurait être d'avoir 8 millions de
personnes qui ont besoin d'avoir recours
à l'aide alimentaire il faut augmenter
les revenus il faut un revenu socle et
la France est engagé au niveau
international en 2015 elle a dit je vais
éradiquer la grande pauvreté dans mon
pays comme tous les pays du monde la
grande pauvreté en France c'est au moins
700 euros par mois et par personne
c'est à dire nettement plus qu'un RSA
qui est aujourd'hui à 564
eurosa notamment par rapport au niveau
de l'activité il y a est-ce qu'il faut
élargir ça aux jeunes ce sont deux
sujets je pense non moi je veux surtout
pas botter en touche mais Esther Duflot
fait des superbes économiques qui
notamment montrent que les inégalités
sont quand même bien moins importantes
en France que dans les pays qu'elle
étudie de près et notamment non mais
au travail où on a dû mettre en place
des aides massives parce que les gens
n'avaient aucune protection sociale ça
n'enlève rien à ce qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure donc faut surtout pas donner
l'impression qu'on oublie c'est plus
démunis mais éradiquer la pauvreté c'est
aussi c'est aussi créer du travail pour
tous c'est créer de la formation pour
tous c'est sortir les enfants pauvres
des quartiers des villes populaires qui
sont aujourd'hui presque condamnés à la
pauvreté on met cinq générations en
sortir pour s'assurer que un enfant
pauvre aujourd'hui ne sera pas un pauvre
demain il faut s'occuper des plus
démunis mais il faut aussi tout faire
pour les en sortir et je pense que la
formation l'aide à l'emploi l'aide aux
entreprises permet aussi de faire ça
très bien pour terminer ce débat je
voudrais vous interroger sur le climat
il y a deux ans maintenant presque jour
pour jour les gilets jaunes
manifestaient et on pouvait même parler
de conjonction sociale du pays comment
vous vous sentez les choses aujourd'hui
le basculement dans la pauvreté ça peut
être de la colère aussi vous savez on a
nous observation avec des gens qui ont
travaillé de du climat de l'ambiance
au printemps c'était de la peur cette
peur elle s'est transformée en colère
chez les travailleurs du public comme
les travailleurs du privé et chez les
retraités elle s'est transformée en
tristesse
donc c'est ça il y a une profonde
lassitude une profonde fatigue
psychologique et une une colère qui est
pas forcément dirigée assez assez
prégnante et ça on y répond comment on y
répond pas par de la confiance et par de
la protection la confiance c'est donner
avoir qu'il y a
une autre situation possible et la
protection c'est de faire en sorte que
comme c'est le cas pour c'est vrai
nombre de salariés qui ont l'activité
partielle pendant cette période
difficile et bien c'est pour montrer que
pour tous il va y avoir une forme de
protections elle est aussi parmi les
commerçants la vue récemment donc il
faut essayer de la traiter de la
canaliser et de donner des perspectives
d'avenir ça c'est vrai que c'est
essentiel il faut arriver à longer
l'horizon c'est très compliqué quand
vous risquez d'attraper un virus ou de
perdre votre job dans les 24 heures qui
viennent mais on essaye de le faire en
tout cas merci à vous restez avec moi
Laurent Berger merci évidemment c'est un
sujet dont on va continuer à parler
j'espère le moins longtemps possible
mais malheureusement il est là il est
encore devant nous je voudrais vous
entendre sur le dialogue social un petit
peu dans cette crise vos relations avec
le président Laurent Berger on le sait
n'ont pas toujours été des meilleurs
c'est la séquence quand témoin
[Musique]
en êtes-vous avec Emmanuel Macron
Laurent Berger la CFDT partenaire
historique de la gauche au pouvoir vous
avez peu goûté on peut le dire la
manière avec laquelle il vous a traité
au départ de ce quinquennat sur les sur
les réformes sociales Macron berger je
t'aime moi non plus c'est un sujet qui
m'a été vraiment vous regardez vous
réagissez merci à vous la clé d'une
bonne relation tout le monde le sait
c'est la communication sauf qu'entre ces
deux-là avant même la toute première
rencontre c'était mal parti nous avons
des partenaires sociaux qui sont
insuffisamment présents ou vivant si je
veux dire dans la branche et dans
l'entreprise beaucoup moins que dans la
plupart des pays européens c'est ce qui
nous a conduit à avoir des partenaires
sociaux qui bien souvent font beaucoup
plus de politiques que de dialogue
social plus de politique que de
dialogues Emmanuel Macron le candidat ne
mâche pas ses mots alors forcément quand
il était lu président Laurent Berger
passe à l'attaque par les pistolaire
vous étiez une interlocuteur privilégié
précédent qu'un Kena ça n'est plus ça
c'est une formule le ce qui est sûr il
le sait le lendemain de son élection je
lui ai fait une lettre ouverte auprès de
la République en disant partager le
pouvoir mais cette lettre reste sans
réponse d'un œil extérieur il faut le
dire cela ne présage pas une grande
histoire d'amour
le quinquennat débute donc au pas de
charge avec d'abord les ordonnances
travail ensuite la réforme de la SNCF et
la grande maison tente entre Laurent
Berger et l'exécutif continue je pense
que le Président de la République
récolte ce qu'il s'aime le président de
la République il n'aime pas la nuance
dans la confrontation des idées il
préfère le bloc contre blocs
jaune un peu comme les Gil et Laurent
Berger le Martel il y en a eu des
alertes Macron veut imposer une relation
directe avec le peuple qui est
dangereuse pour la démocratie vient
alors le grand débat national et un
espoir d'un mariage de raison mais
encore une fois Laurent Berger se sent
en mal de reconnaissance il n'y a pas de
sortie positive de ce grand débat
possible donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
vraiment maintenant qu'on prenne le
temps de discuter des solutions la CFDT
avec d'autres a fait les propositions
autour d'un pacte social écologique
j'espère qu'on sera entendu quand
Laurent Berger leader de la salle d'été
appelle à une réunion des syndicats des
associations pour construire un impact
social de la conversion écologique vous
lui répondez quoi ce soir oui on se met
autour de la table j'entends ce qu'il a
proposé je ne crois pas que ce que
demande les gilets jaunes c'est une
grande conférence avec des responsables
politiques et des responsables syndicaux
le temps passe et les crispations
continuent avec notamment l'assurance
chômage mais surtout la réforme des
retraites et son âge pivot symbole du
différent qui oppose et manuel Macron au
leader de la CFDT il y a des centaines
de réunions qui ont été organisées avec
les représentants syndicaux depuis
janvier 2018 des centaines et ça va
continuer pour essayer d'élaborer le bon
système le bon compromis social le bon
contrat social le projet qui a été
annoncé par le gouvernement porte à une
ligne rouge énorme c'est cet âge
d'équilibre et sur ce point Laurent
Berger se fait entendre le retrait de
l'âge pivot c'est une victoire pour tous
les salariés mais cette réforme comme
toutes les autres est mis entre
parenthèses le temps de gérer la crise
sanitaire
alors Laurent Berger est-ce que ça va
mieux avec Macron aujourd'hui c'est pas
le sujet j'ai envie de dire est-ce que
vous êtes suffisamment associé
ça ça compte est-ce que les
organisations syndicales sont
suffisamment associées et dans le
reportage il est sous-entendu que ce
qu'on chercherait c'est une forme de
reconnaissance je vais vous dire
franchement moi dans mon parcours
militant et de responsable syndical je
m'en moque de la reconnaissance
personnelle de la part du pouvoir mais
le reportage montre bien que vous
essayez de peser sur le feu et que la
porte est restée justement c'est sur le
fond sur le fond et sur le fond oui je
pense que on n'a pas souvent été entendu
je vais vous prendre un exemple vous
vous citer fort justement et c'est très
important la lettre ouverte que j'ai
fait que j'ai écrite dans le monde une
semaine après l'élection elle disait
quoi elle disait attention monsieur le
Président vous avez été élu
parce que en face il y avait le Front
National et heureusement que vous avez
été élu vous avez été élu sur une
société qui est fracturée sur un peuple
assez divisé qui préfère parfois
l'altercation au débat d'idées et et à
la construction de propositions avec un
monde en forte transition besoin
d'écologie besoin de justice sociale une
pauvreté qui qui
après et j'avais dit vous pourrez pas
faire tout seul ça s'appelait partager
le pouvoir vous ne pourrez pas faire
tout seul deux ans et demi après il de
sépare rien fait moi je ne suis pas dans
un bilan ou tout serait noir durant
depuis 2017 il y a eu des choses qui ont
été faites et qui et qui qui sont
intéressantes je vais vous dire
franchement la réaction du gouvernement
face à la crise qu'on a traversé sur le
soutien à l'économie et le soutien à
travers l'activité partielle c'est une
bonne réponse et bien deux ans et demi
après je crois qu'il y a pas eu
suffisamment encore cette
co-construction et je crois que c'est ce
qui nous oppose fondamentalement une
forme de des partenaires sociaux une
forme de verticalité qui a été opérée et
ça ne se mesure pas au nombre de
réunions c'est vrai que nous sommes dans
un pays où lorsque vous êtes un
représentant syndical vous voulez
discuter avec telle ou tel ministre vous
pouvez et toutes les organisations
syndicales peuvent le faire mais ce dont
il est question c'est que les cautions
la société est épaisse au sens où elle
représente des contradictions elle a
besoin avec des situations extrêmement
diverses les questions qui sont à
traiter sont très compliquées il y a pas
de moi ce qui m'énerve dans le débat
public c'est le la facilité donc ça n'a
pas vraiment changé
ce que je dis c'est qu'il y a eu des
inflexions un certain moment
dans la volonté de discuter de partager
on a voulu discuter sur les retraites on
leur avait dit surtout ne mettre ne
faites pas de mesures paramétrique ça
mettra le bazar concentrons-nous sur un
système plus juste sur une réforme ce
qu'on avait appelé systémique
ou en tout cas c'est tout d'actualité
donc ce que je veux dire par ce que je
veux dire c'est que et moi le passé je
m'en fiche un peu ce qui m'intéresse
c'est maintenant maintenant on l'a dit
tout à l'heure dans une société qui
enquête de sens je crois en quête de
commun qui est en quête de justice et
moi j'ai envie de rajouter une société
qui devrait être guidée par un souci de
solidarité et ça face à ce cette
situation très compliquée une ambiance
très compliquée on a besoin de
confrontation d'idées on a besoin de
faire ensemble et quand je dis ensemble
c'est ce sont les acteurs territoriaux
avec les élus locaux ce sont les
associations qui sont le maillage du
lien dans notre société a besoin ce sont
les acteurs syndicaux et pas trop nous
et patronaux c'est-à-dire que moi
lorsqu'on est à ma place on ne demande
pas à ce que toutes les idées de la CFDT
soient reprises on demande à ce qu'on
puisse co-construire et ça aujourd'hui
c'est encore compliqué mais ça veut pas
dire qu'on n'est pas écouté c'est pas
dire que des choses ont avancées
notamment depuis le début de cette crise
suffit pas voilà on va retenir ça on
entend que c'est de la demi teinte très
clairement oui parce que pendant le
début de la crise en mars avril
objectivement à chaque fois qu'on a posé
un problème on a on a été écouté pour
écouter rechercher les solutions modulo
ce que j'ai ce qu'on vient de discuter
sur la pauvreté mais encore une fois
maintenant il va falloir se projeter il
va falloir redonner confiance à notre
société parce que je voudrais vous
interroger sur l'actualité du débat qui
se tient en ce moment à l'Assemblée sur
sur la sécurité globale mais d'un mot
sortir de la crise agir vite pensée loin
si on commençait à penser à la près on
n'est pas quelle serait la grande
réforme quelle serait la grande réforme
qu'il faudrait faire sur le plan social
si on voulait penser à la presse et je
pense qu'on doit y être c'est on devrait
se dire c'est quoi les indicateurs de
progrès dans une société qu'est-ce qui
doit guider nos actions l'action
publique mais aussi nos actions
collectives et je pense qu'on peut
mesurer le PIB comme on le fait
aujourd'hui
il faut aussi qui sont de la santé la
question de l'éducation de la pauvreté
du respect de la biodiversité des
inégalités soient aussi et puis après le
deuxième grand réforme parce que ça ce
serait une forme de direction à prendre
la deuxième réforme je crois qu'il
faudra qu'on redise très qu'on rediscute
la redistribution des richesses et de la
contribution de tous à égalité j'ai
envie de dire au bien commun c'est à
dire à travers la fiscalité et donc là
oui il y a un sujet de contribution des
plus riches que disait Louis Gallois
tout à l'heure ce gouvernement cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale
Gérald Darmanin le ministre de
l'Intérieur a confirmé qu'il va proposer
un amendement pour préciser l'article 24
l'article 24 de la proposition de loi
sur la sécurité globale article très
controversé vous le savez sur
l'interdiction à certaines conditions de
diffuser les visages de policiers en
opération on va d'abord écouter le
ministre de l'Intérieur
la première guerre qu'évidemment mais
comme l'article 24 les déjà écrit que la
liberté de la presse est totale mais
peut-être faut-il l'écrire davantage
parce que la liberté de la presse est un
point important et c'est évidemment un
point qu'il faut évoquer dans le texte
de loi si certains pensent qu'il y a un
doute il n'y en a pas et je le
préciserai en tout cas ce sera ce que je
proposerai au Premier ministre et au
rapporteur avec un X et as et
deuxièmement introduire le mot
manifestement c'est à dire que les
images qui manifestement souhaitent
nuire ou veulent nuire aux forces de
l'ordre ce sont des c'est pas une
réécriture monsieur le député la date
c'est des précisions mais qui feront
naître sans doute mais qu'il n'est pas
déposé un amendement gouvernemental afin
de faire voter je l'espère par la plus
large majorité l'article 24 pour
protéger nos forces de l'ordre Laurent
Berger est-ce que cet amendement peut
suffire à apaiser sur sur cette question
je ne crois pas même s'il faudra
regarder mais vous savez ça c'est c'est
dramatique ce sujet là parce que on
voudrait nous faire croire qu'il
faudrait choisir entre la nécessaire de
protection de fonctionnaires qui font
leur travail et la liberté de la presse
bah non faut pas choisir il faut faire
les deux mais la liberté de la presse
c'est sacré tout comme la liberté
d'expression et donc oui c'est normal
que des journalistes fassent leur
travail se rendent à des manifestations
sans se déclarer c'est normal diffusé
des images ou à la télévision par contre
les images est anormales c'est que des
personnes sur les réseaux sociaux
pointent des noms des adresses de
fonctionnaires de police pour les mettre
en danger mais il faut raison garder
c'est au gouvernement de faire ce
compromis et ce compromis oui nous on
demande le retrait de cet article ce
compromis ça peut pas être au détriment
de la liberté d'informer merci beaucoup
merci Laurent Berger d'avoir été notre
invité sortir de la crise agir vite
pensez loin c'est chez
calma Lévi
présent une page sur les vaccins je vous
le disais c'est sans doute des meilleurs
nouvelles de ces derniers jours mais
est-ce que la France est prête d'un
point de vue de sa logistique est-ce
qu'elle est prête à vacciner toute sa
population décryptage tout de suite
[Musique]
alors combien de doses va-t-on commander
a-t-on la logistique pour la mise en
oeuvre et qui sera prioritaire un
monsieur ou une madame vaccin d'ailleurs
pourrait être nommée dans les jours qui
viennent la question des vaccins mode
d'emploi fait avec Nathalie Gillard
[Musique]
quel vaccin sont disponibles aucun
vaccin n'est disponible pour le moment
mais après des essais cliniques bien
avancés et prometteur 2 seront bientôt
sur le marché le vaccin Pfizer biotech
développé par un duo américain et
allemand il serait efficace à 95%.
l'autre c'est le moderna du nom d'une
société de biotechnologie américaine il
serait efficace à 94% dans le monde plus
d'une vingtaine de laboratoires sont
engagés dans cette course au vaccin aux
enjeux sanitaires et financiers
colossaux qui achète les doses avant
même que les vaccins ne soient au point
les différents pays se positionnent pour
pouvoir en acheter dès leur mise sur le
marché pour la France cela se joue au
niveau européen l'Union européenne a
signé cinq contrats avec des
laboratoires un sixième est en cours de
négociation la distribution s'opérera en
fonction de la population de chaque pays
via ce système le gouvernement français
a déjà pris réservé 90 millions de de
quoi potentiellement vacciner 45
millions de personnes pour 2021 Paris a
mis un milliard et demi d'euros de côté
pour financer la logistique et payer les
vaccins qui seront gratuits pour les
Français comment se déroulera la
vaccination la campagne ne démarrera pas
avant que toutes les garanties de
sécurité soient remplies à promis le
gouvernement peut être des janvier les
soignants et les personnes vulnérables
seront-ils prioritaires les généralistes
pourront-ils vacciner faudra-t-il aller
dans des centres spécialisés la
stratégie de vaccination n'est pas
encore définie ce qui est sûr c'est que
ce sera un défi logistique le vaccin de
Pfizer doit être gardé au froid à moins
80 degrés il faut trouver comment le
stocker et l'acheminer le ministère de
la Santé adore et déjà acheter 50 super
congélateurs pour le conserve
bonsoir Gérald kirdec merci d'être là
vous êtes médecin urgentiste et
consultant pour LCI et TF1 bienvenue sur
ce plateau vous êtes député en marche
des Français qui vivent en Asie et
médecins de formation Christian brechot
est avec nous via Skype depuis les
États-Unis est-ce qu'il est là Christian
brechot bonsoir monsieur vous êtes
médecin chercheur et ancien directeur de
l'Institut Pasteur et puis un peu plus
tard dans l'émission peut-être on va le
voir on parlera avec Jérémy Pelletier
qui coordonne les études de la Fondation
Jean Jaurès bonsoir Jérémy la Fondation
Jean Jaurès qui a publié une étude
passionnante sur le mouvement
anti-vaccin et sur l'état de l'opinion
face à ces nouveaux vaccins qui arrivent
je vais commencer avec vous Christian
brechot on est à un tournant fondamental
avec ses différentes annonces Pfizer
moderna et les autres est-ce qu'on peut
dire d'une façon certaine avec ses
premiers résultats très encourageants
qu'on aura un vaccin sur pour la
population de la planète dans les
prochaines semaines
alors oui je pense votre reportage
d'ailleurs l'introduit très bien on a
vécu au cours des 10 derniers jours une
évolution vraiment très très forte et
très positive je crois qu'on peut dire
c'est exactement ça on peut dire oui on
sait maintenant qu'on peut faire un
vaccin contre ce coronavirus qui était
tous sauf évident il y a quelques mois
et bien sûr on a besoin d'autres
informations bien sûr on doit être
prudent on doit attendre les rapports
finaux on doit attendre les
autorisations de la FDA de l'agence
européenne etc donc on est tous d'accord
là-dessus mais oui on a maintenant la
preuve qu'on pourra avoir un vaccin
contre ce coronavirus
mise au point
réalise au point un vaccin
de cette façon de quoi s'agit-il
précisément
alors je vais vous répondre sur l'ARN
mais il faut bien savoir que à côté de
ça il y a d'autres vaccins qui vont
également marcher et des résultats sont
moins bien connus mais qui sont en train
qui ont en train d'arriver les Russes
ont donné peu d'informations mais leur
vaccins est en train de marcher et c'est
un vaccin qui est basé sur adénovirus et
il faut pas oublier ce que font les
chinois mais pour votre question sur les
ARN le principe si vous voulez qui
effectivement est très novateur c'est
que vous injectez directement non pas
des particules virales non pas des
structures je dirais remanier recombiner
qui exprime le gène d'intérêt mais vous
injectez directement l'ARN qui fait que
quand il entre dans la cellule la
cellule va directement synthétiser
l'antigène la protéine du virus contre
lesquels vous voulez stimuler la réponse
de l'autre donc c'est ça c'est une
approche extrêmement directe de la
vaccination et qu'il en future
d'ailleurs permet de bien s'adapter à
d'éventuelles variations ou à d'autres
virus et le fait que ce soit la première
fois ne rend pas ce vaccin moins fiable
si vous voulez de toute façon que ce
soit pour ce vaccin ou pour les
adénovirus ou pour d'autres vaccins
parce que on va sûrement y revenir il y
a vraiment d'autres procédés vaccinaux
qui sont encore dans la cour c'est ça
qu'il faut bien comprendre mais de toute
façon ce qui est le juge de paix entre
guillemets c'est l'avis des experts les
autorités FDA et donc ce vaccin n'est
n'a pas je dirais de pas droit par
rapport à d'autres vaccins il va être
évalué comme les autres et pour
l'instant ce qui est quand même vraiment
très intéressant c'est que dans les deux
études Pfizer by yo-entech et dans
l'étude moderna l'étude intérimaire mais
enfin une porte sur quand même pas mal
pas mal de gens elle ne montre pas
d'effets secondaires importants dernière
petite question et puis je fais circuler
la parole
la France dans tout ça l'Institut
Pasteur et Sanofi on est à la traîne ou
pas
alors on peut voir les choses de manière
à pour répondre de façon très très
simple on est on est derrière la preuve
donc ça c'est un fait maintenant encore
une fois et je le dis pas uniquement
pour le vaccin pasteur parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'autres vaccins les questions
sur la durée de la protection
l'efficacité dans les populations à
risque votre reportage va très bien dit
on envisage de vacciner bien sûr les le
personnel de santé mais également les
personnes âgées les diabétiques les
personnes fragiles quelle va être
l'efficacité de ces vaccins dans ces
populations on ne sait pas pour
l'instant et il y a d'autres approches
vaccinales comme c'est de pasteur et
comme d'autres qui peut-être je dis bien
peut-être pourrait donner des
protections supérieures donc il va
falloir attendre maintenant pourquoi on
est en retard on peut peut-être y
revenir si vous le souhaitez mais je
pense que ça s'explique par beaucoup de
choses aux États-Unis et en particulier
par la qualité des investissements et
des interactions entre Acad et
partenaires industriels les Américains
qui investissent massivement dans la
recherche Gérald kerzadi évidemment
énormément de questions sur sur les
vaccins d'abord quand même quelle
rapidité non est-ce que il faut se
féliciter on est à moins d'un an de
cette épidémie on a déjà des vaccins il
faut se féliciter oui de la recherche
qui avance plus vite que d'habitude et
la technique étant innovante ne
nécessite pas les mêmes développements
donc c'est pour ça que ça va plus vite
c'est pas un vaccin comme comme un
vaccin a été mis au point sur des œufs
de poules par exemple donc c'est en fait
on prend le code génétique c'est ce que
Chris André show a expliqué on prend le
code génétique on ne vous injecte pas de
virus c'est pas du virus atténué c'est
pas du virus tué etc c'est le code
génétique et il va s'intégrer dans vos
propres cellules et les vos propres
cellules vont fabriquer une petite
partie du virus ce qu'on appelle les
spécules la coque du virus qui est
inoffensive puisque c'est pas ça qui va
pouvoir vous infecter et par contre ça
va être reconnu immédiatement par vos
cellules immunitaires et donc les
anticorps vont être vont être développés
donc ça explique que c'est plus rapide
pour être c'est pas le vaccin qui va
arrêter automatiquement la circulation
du virus à prendre du temps c'est pas la
fin du covid efficace il faut une
couverture vaccinale efficace et oui il
y a plein de de conditions en revanche
c'est une arme extrêmement importante
donc la rapidité oui c'est bien mais
attention là quand j'entends 1er janvier
tout le monde va être des vacciner on va
commencer la vaccination il faut être
c'est pas possible enfin j'ai assez dans
un mois et demi ne serait-ce que les
autorités réglementaires etc c'est
impossible et j'allais dire il faut pas
confondre vitesse et précipitations
aussi il faut peut-être se donner un peu
de recul il faut organiser les choses
donc quels sont les plus grands
obstacles est-ce qu'on sait qu'ils
devraient conserver à moins 80 degrés
pour celui de Pfizer
modernement et c'est beaucoup plus
acceptable en termes de distribution il
va falloir qu'il y a une stratégie
vaccinale aussi mais avant même ça il
faut que les fourches codines des des
évaluations pour garantir la sécurité
c'est la FDA aux États-Unis c'est les
autorités européennes ou françaises
c'est fondamental qui est une évaluation
ne serait-ce que pour que les gens on
ait confiance dans ce vaccin pas parce
que il est sorti tout de suite que il
faut tout de suite se faire vacciner
évidemment attendre que toutes les
garanties que tous les comités d'experts
indépendants
des protocoles très strict à respecter
la question de la logistique il va
falloir les entreprises dans les
stratégies pourquoi la stratégie de la
France on nous dit déjà
Gérald gerzec bon bah janvier il faut
pas rêver alors ça c'est sur le plan
technique parce qu'il y a la mise au
point des protocoles d'évaluation soit
par la FD aux États-Unis soit par
l'Agence européenne du médicament ce
sont deux autorités qui sont très
rigoureuses sur les critères qui
permettent de valider d'autoriser la
mise sur le marché d'un nouveau produit
de santé ça c'est incompréhension
européenne qui décide c'est l'Agence du
Médicament ensuite s'agissant des
commandes actuellement c'est la
Commission européenne effectivement qui
a plusieurs centaines de millions de
doses en négociations auprès de
plusieurs laboratoires il y a pas
seulement auprès de de Pfizer et by
human tech et ensuite tout va dépendre
quant à la stratégie il y a des éléments
que nous n'avons pas c'est faudra-t-il
une ou deux doses ça va peut-être
dépendre on parle de deux sociétés donc
on divise tout le temps le nombre de
doses produites par deux pour savoir
combien de personnes d'autres qui vont
arriver qui sont peut-être en une dose
vous voyez que selon le nombre de doses
le temps qu'il faut entre deux doigts la
façon dont ça réagit si je vous pose la
question de la France et de l'Europe
est-ce qu'on est en retard ou est-ce que
on est un peu en train de se faire avoir
parlé d'Américains c'est parce que il y
a eu pas mal de prise de parole et
notamment d'un chercheur français c'est
moderna c'est un chercheur français à la
base
moderna c'était laboratoire américain
qui a semé un peu le trouble en
expliquant c'est Stéphane Mancel son nom
en expliquant que l'Europe avait pris du
retard qu'elle n'avait pas passé tous
les contrats en premier contrairement à
Donald Trump qui l'avait fait on va
l'écouter et puis vous réagissez après
selon les quantités qui veulent ce que
c'est des grosses quantités vu le la
population européenne les livraisons
sont plus étalées que s'ils avaient
commandé il y a un mois que s'ils
avaient commandé il y a 6 mois plus
attendre plus ça sera décalé dans le
temps il y a plein de choses
administratives et dossiers des trucs
des alignements entre les pays c'est
juste compliqué à gérer quand vous êtes
27 par rapport à quand vous êtes tout
seul il a absolument raison c'est vrai
aux États-Unis c'est un pays là où en
Europe nous sommes 27 pour autant ça ne
veut pas dire que on est handicapé par
rapport aux autres parce que je croyais
qu'il y avait un guichet unique pour une
fois c'est la Commission qui décide pour
tout encore une fois il y a la chance
européenne des médicaments qui doivent
valider ensuite il y a l'organisation de
la commande et de la distribution et
tout ça mais on n'a pas encore le vaccin
comme le dit à docteur
dit en dernier on n'a pas dit qu'on
serait servi en dernier
on n'a pas dit qu'on serait servi en
dernier eux ont des méthodes qui font
que les décisions vont plus vite les
approvisionnements vont peut-être ça
reste à démontrer la gestion de la crise
je pense chacun d'obélis devant sa porte
donc attendons de voir
eux sont peut-être un peu d'avance ça
reste à démontrer ce qui est certain
aujourd'hui c'est que tant la Commission
européenne c'est saisie du sujet pour
voir comment commander et comment
organiser la distribution et la France
de son côté c'est saisi du sujet avec
une équipe auprès du ministre de la
Santé qui est en train de réfléchir à la
stratégie il faut réfléchir à plusieurs
stratégies puisque tout dépendra du
vaccin et de la façon dont il est
admises
sont dotés d'une structure extrêmement
dotée justement sur le plan financier
qui s'appelle le barbare qui est une
structure qui va justement faire de la
recherche investir coin investir avec
les industriels ce que n'a pas l'Europe
ce que n'a pas la France non plus donc
le retard il a été pris sur la recherche
sur le développement ensuite Stéphane
mancelle et dans une logique de business
il dit le premier qui commande c'est
celui qui sera livré le premier
ça peut être un peu choquant aussi quand
on entend ce ce genre d'accueil il est
très bien il est très à l'américaine
mais le retard c'est clair qu'il y ait
après encore une fois on n'est pas un
mois près moi je préfère avoir un mois
de retard toutes les garanties
sanitaires de sécurité et faire adhérer
les professionnels de santé et les
Français parce que c'est pas une
instance plutôt que de se précipiter un
tout petit effet secondaire qu'on
n'aurait pas vu sur les effets sur les
premières études même sur des milliers
de personnes si vous vaccinez des
millions de personnes là vous allez
avoir une incidence de cet effet
secondaire et franchement je pense qu'il
faut vraiment avoir
c'est pas du tout puisque on est dans
plein dans le test pour l'instant on
sait pas mais un effet secondaire qui
interviendrait inca sur un million si
vous vaccinez 40000 personnes dans les
siècles cliniques vous ne le voyez pas
des goûts vacciner à million il va
apparaître
vous venez justement sur la question
d'un éventuel retard des Européens que
nous sommes dans cette dans cette course
au vaccin
en fait ce que je voulais dire également
sur l'aspect
logistro se fixer sur le - 70 de Pfizer
et ce genre de choses
bayotech est déjà en train de préparer
des annonces et travailler sur la
stabilité je pense que ce qu'on va voir
très rapidement c'est en fait que ces
vaccins vont pouvoir être distribués
d'une façon relativement je dis bien
relativement simple et l'autre point il
faudrait dire c'est que on est tous
d'accord qu'il faut les autorisations je
les dis et ça vient d'être redit on est
tous d'accord
les Américains vont vacciner à partir de
la fin de l'année et ça va arriver et je
pense qu'on va on est face à une
accélération qui est tout à fait tout à
fait remarquable je pense pas qu'on
prenne des risques actuellement en
faisant ça parce qu'encore une fois ça
passera comme ça a été dit par les
autorisations de la FDA donc je crois
qu'effectivement si je dis ça c'est que
oui il faut se donner toutes les mesures
de sécurité on est tous d'accord oui il
y a d'autres vaccins j'ai vraiment j'ai
des repris tout à l'heure quand vous
m'avez posé la question mais il est
quand même très probable qu'on va avoir
des vaccinations dans des groupes qui
ont soutien était bien défini par le
Conseil Scientifique dès le mois de
juillet faut quand même pas faut quand
même pas oublier ça il y a déjà eu un
travail de fait donc on connaît les
populations qu'il faut vacciner on va
voir arriver des doses les Américains
ont été vaccinés avec des autorisations
de la FDA donc c'est pas n'importe quoi
on a des études donc je pense qu'on va
voir une accélération des choses et on
va assister à un assouplissement d'un
logistique
sur la logistique on se souvient du H1
et de ses immenses entrepôts dans
lesquels les Français étaient appelés
à faire vacciner comment vous voyez les
choses aujourd'hui
est-ce que est-ce que ça va se répéter
alors écoutez très franchement et c'est
pas du tout pour fuir la question je
pense que c'est pas mon rôle il y a des
gens qui sont en train de réfléchir à ça
et c'est pas du tout pour fuir mais la
manière dont je vois dont je comprends
et je crois que ça correspond à ce qui a
été dit sur votre plateau je crois que
dans un premier temps on aura besoin
quand même d'avoir des centres assez
spécialisé quel que soit l'organisation
parce qu'il va falloir que tout ça soit
bien contrôlé soit fait sous forme
d'études où on suive très très bien les
effets secondaires éventuels dont je
vois pas comment on pourrait commencer
avec une vaccination qui se ferait
n'importe où alors après comment seront
organisés ces centres ça ça n'est pas à
moi de le dire merci Christian brechot
je voudrais qu'on termine ce débat sur
les anti-vaccins enfin en tout cas les
inquiétudes qui sont très fortes
rebonsoir Jérémy Pelletier je le disais
vous êtes le coordinateur des des études
à la Fondation Jean Jaurès la fondation
qui qui publie une étude sur l'état
d'esprit des Français avec ce vaccin
contre le covid qui arrive on le sait un
seul un français sur deux en France
déclare ce vouloir se faire vacciner
c'est très peu par rapport à nos voisins
européens comment vous l'expliquez quels
sont les raisons de ce qui refusent
quels sont ces raisons qui le mettent en
avant
alors d'abord il y a une vraie
spécificité française effectivement
comme Blendi Myriam
vis-à-vis des vaccins et vis-à-vis de la
question vaccinale vous savez ça fait
longtemps que la Fondation Jean Jaurès
publie et réalise des études sur les
théories du complot et on s'était aperçu
quand on avait fait cette première vague
d'études en 2018 que la théorie à
laquelle les Français adhéraient le plus
et la théorie que les Français avaient
vu le plus passer durant leur vie
c'était la théorie vous savez qui dit
que l'industrie pharmaceutique serait de
mèche avec le ministère de la Santé pour
cacher au grand public la réalité sur
une nocivité potentielle des vaccins
donc il y a déjà en fait ce terreau ce
terreau là il est que aujourd'hui sur
les théories du complot si on prend des
théories du complot ce qui est en tête
de gondole c'est vrai que c'est la
question et une question qui concerne
les vaccins ensuite pour ce qui est des
personnes qui sont les plus réactifs
justement à la vaccination et qu'on peut
pas forcément qualifier de de
complotisme mais qui sont des personnes
défiantes vis-à-vis de la question de la
vaccination en gros on peut avoir
on peut définir je dirais trois
catégories vous avez effectivement la
jeune génération plus vous êtes vieux
plus vous avancez dans l'âge plus vous
avez tendance à dire que vous êtes
d'accord pour vous faire vacciner contre
la covid de la covid-19 plus vous êtes
jeune plus vous êtes réticent la raison
principale c'est qu'en gros vous avez la
jeune génération qui doute en fait de
l'efficacité du vaccin en disant que bon
globalement il n'y a pas assez de recul
mais surtout qu'en gros c'est une
génération qui ne se sent pas à risque
et donc qui ne juge pas utile par
définition de se faire vacciner parce
que je voudrais faire réagir mes invités
d'un mot est-ce qu'il y a plus de aussi
chez les femmes
vous avez plus de refuge chez les femmes
absolument vous avez quasiment une femme
sur deux qui dit aujourd'hui je ne me
ferai pas vacciner contre la covid-19
contre 35% chez les hommes les femmes
sont beaucoup plus inquiète des effets
secondaires d'un potentiel vaccin c'est
très clair en tout cas dans l'enquête et
c'est un élément en tout cas central je
pense pour la pédagogie qui va falloir
faire sur le vaccin contre la covid
merci beaucoup Jérémy faut préciser
aussi que la confiance vis-à-vis des
scientifiques et bien moi que au début
de la crise sanitaire comment on fait
face à ça engine comment vous allez
rassurer après tout elles sont légitimes
ces inquiétudes j'aimerais avoir la
réponse et pouvoir être une peut-être
une fée pour expliquer comment comment
il faut avoir confiance c'est un vrai
défi la confiance dans la science
au-delà de la situation pandémique
actuelle elle est ancienne ça n'est pas
quelque chose de récent je ne sais pas
l'expliquer comme médecin comme
praticien je pense qu'on a une part de
responsabilité nous-mêmes nous avons
besoin d'être plus transparent d'être
plus clair dans nos explications quand
un jeune dit qu'il ne souhaite pas se
faire vacciner il faut aussi qu'il faut
comprendre qu'il ne voit pas la maladie
le risque pour lui-même on voit pas le
médecin en gros de 15 à 55 ans on voit
pas un médecin déjà même malade quand
tout va bien donc tout ça peut
s'expliquer c'est à nous je pense
médecin de reconstruire de rebâtir avec
des gens c'est à VOUS élu de retisser la
confiance vis-à-vis des politiques parce
que c'est scientifiques la France aussi
l'état qui va qui va devoir d'un mot
vous avez même pas 10 secondes massive
on va être sur une stratégie beaucoup
plus ciblée et ça c'est important parce
que la cible ça va être des gens qui
sont plutôt convaincus merci beaucoup et
pardonné
c'était absolument passionnant on va
continuer d'en reparler de ce vaccin que
nous attendons merci Jérémy Pelletier
très belle soirée sur LCP à demain
[Musique]